all right it's a sign of the times
inflation is at a 40-year high and
people need quick ways to make ends meet
that has led to the rise of activity at
pawn shops across the country and here
locally mary jane belliesa gives us a
look at the trend
it's monday morning in east dallas p j
pawn shop has just opened its doors and
already customers are streaming in
[Music]
patrick wade has worked here for 34
years and now owns the place close to
100 chains not quite 200 earrings every
day i help people that don't have help
normally
lending a helping hand has forever been
part of pawning but in the last few
months wade has watched the industry do
a 180 in the past pawning was a luxury
for many of his customers with inflation
at a 40-year high most are now here out
of necessity to make ends meet how often
are you coming here
you say i know everybody here
patrice ward has been loyal to pnj for
20 years i'm hoping to just cover the
gas that i need for my vehicle
maybe food or whatever i need to get
through into my payday
times are hard and ward has four kids
getting rid of a television opposed to
not eating
this raspberry can help you to be a
diplomat and she's not alone for aj
johnson it was a watch he struggled to
part with amount of money that i had to
work with was so sufficient probably two
years ago but since then
things have gone topsy-turvy
according to the national pawn brokers
association 30 million americans are
unbanked or underbanked 20 percent don't
have a bank account at all if you don't
have cash and you don't have a credit
card guess what i'm the next best offer
mary jane boleyeza live local now